[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il a surgi des coulisses mais le public
l'attendait comme s'il revenait à
l'instant de captivité enlevé en
septembre dernier par les islamistes les
matou remonte sur scène entetemps son
histoire est entré dans la légende des
jeunes
cabiles il l' enlevé mais bon il avait
pas baissé les bras quoi toujours
combattif il combat toujours puis c'est
un bon homme qui n'a pas peur de
mourir un chanteur pour deux personnages
il y a les matou le poète il compose en
tamazir la langue berbère ignorée par le
pouvoir mélodie populaire sur l'exil et
l'amour qui font vibrer et danser toutes
les
générations
une culture ancestrale c'est la culture
DEES parents grandspents mes ancêtresvid
je
miden je ne suis pas un politique je
suis ce bonhomme que vous venez de voir
aujourd'hui je suis un
chanteur pourant il y a l'autre partion
matit démocrate desex m renvoyant à dos
les intégristes le gouvernement moment
d'émotion l chanson évo la mémoire
d'unomme politique assassiné
Mohed il s'appelait
[Musique]
Bouab c'était
l'espoir l'espoir de l'Algérie de cette
Algérie qu'on veut plonger qu'on veut
précipiter dans un
[Musique]
chaos sincèrement on est tous avec lui
l'intégrisme nonatisme non durant toute
la soirée lunes matou le poète a ainsi
passé le relais à matou lunes le
politique hier la star de la lutte pour
les Berbères a atteint son
é